hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Spanish psychological
Thriller film called the chalk line
spoilers ahead watch out ants take care
[Music]
the movie starts with Simon and Paula a
couple in their 40s driving on a dimly
lit Road there are police cars
everywhere conducting random searches
shortly after the couple continues their
Journey until they come across a strange
figure on a better look it is revealed
to be a little girl probably the one the
police are looking for she is strangely
walking through the middle of the road
the couple gets out of their car and
calls to her but the little girl does
not respond around the same time a
motorcycle speedily approaches from the
opposite direction but instead of
running away the girl dangerously runs
towards it as a result the motorcycle
ends up crashing and the girl is also
knocked out witnessing this Simon and
Paula immediately take the child to a
hospital and getter admitted the police
also get involved as they try to match
the girl's identity with any of the
missing children's reports however
nothing conclusive comes up after a
while the couple returns home to freshen
up and Paula is seen injecting herself
with something in the bathroom we learn
that this is a secret since she quietly
High hides away the syringe box behind
the bathroom mirror as long as the
mysterious girl's parents are not found
Paula and Simon visit the girl in the
hospital every day the doctor explains
that the girl didn't get knocked out
because of the crash in fact she was
already sick her kidneys have been
damaged to the point that they hardly
work since her arrival the little girl
hasn't uttered a single word but she
reacted strongly when a nurse by the
name of Clara was called the doctors
then concluded that her name is also
Clara with treatment at the hospital she
does recover physically but her mental
state confuses everyone around her
during one visit Paula and Simon head
inside where Clara is kept and we see
her acting hysterically the mystery
around her becomes even denser when the
couple sees that the girl has drawn a
box with chalk around herself and
refuses to get out of it she screams and
fights the hospital officials as they
try to remove her from the box Paula
watches this and tries to pacify Clara
surprisingly she succeeds and the two
instantly form a connection later the
couple returns home but they cannot stop
thinking about the poor child especially
Paula she always sees Clara when she
closes her eyes the next day when they
visit the hospital the doctor informs
them that Clara keeps breaking down when
she is moved outside of her chalk line
the doctor remains concerned about the
mental growth and health of such a young
child hence she determines that the
hospital is not the safest or best place
for Clara to stay temporarily as of now
Paula has already established a close
relationship with the girl since she is
able to comfort and calm her down when
she gets aggressive so the hospital
officials decide that Paula and her
husband could provide a good home
environment where they could gain
Clara's trust make her open up and find
out about her identity after bringing
Clara home the couple both try their
best to make the girl feel safe but the
very first thing that strikes out about
her is that she keeps herself restricted
within a square or circle on the floor
drawn with chalk Clara does not ever
move outside of the boundary that is
drawn around her and is extremely scared
to even try to do so I've heard of the
Flores lava but never the floor is
Hopscotch to cope with this polishes
Clara how the lines of chalk can be
rubbed and a new line can be made
Additionally the couple clears their
floor space as much as possible and
draws lines or Pathways all over the
house so that young Clara gets used to
moving freely inside One Day Gloria the
hospital psychologist visits the house
and tries to make Clara talk she
forcefully gets the mysterious girl out
of the chalk line in response to this
Clara begins acting up hysterically and
becomes aggressive during all this the
psychologist manages to record some
words spluttered by Clara this reveals
that the mysterious girl isn't mute but
is just refusing to talk Paula finds out
about this and immediately draws a chalk
line to confine Clara the latter is
moved by the gesture and she hugs Paula
warmly as time passes on Clara gradually
lets the couple get close to her and
even starts growing affection towards
Paula she makes small paper ornaments
for her foster mom however one day a
strange incident occurs when a pregnant
neighbor visits them Paul serves bread
and jam to the neighbor who munches
through the food until she starts to
bleed from her mouth after a while she
coughs and manages to spit out a big
Shard of glass that was in the food the
neighbor is rushed to the hospital and
when Simon later investigates the matter
he finds that the container in which
they kept the jam is filled with several
other glass shards taken aback Simon
puts two and two together concluding
that it's the doing of their new guest
Clara but Paula refuses to entertain
that thought besides this means we can
sue the pants off that jam company just
then Gloria the psychologist visits them
to discuss her new findings she plays
Clara's recordings and it becomes clear
that the little girl actually speaks
German she then asserts that Clara isn't
speaking because everyone around her has
been using only Spanish while the police
start to look into missing children's
cases in Germany the doctors use German
colleagues to communicate with Clara she
appears to understand everything but
still remains extremely shy and
introverted it is evident that she is
haunted by something brutal that
happened in her past as days passed by
Paula keeps trying to communicate with
Clara but to no avail in one instance
she even gets hurt when Clara angrily
kicks her away Simon gets a hint of this
and he is absolutely enraged that the
little girl is turning out to be such an
evil child hence he has started
disliking Clara and wants to give her
back to the hospital one morning Paula
is having a drink when she also gets a
glass Shard stuck in her neck Clara sees
her struggle but does nothing about it
while Paula goes to the washroom to get
it out of her throat Clara mysteriously
disappears from the house Paula is
absolutely convinced that the girl has
been kidnapped because Claire would
never go beyond the chalk marked
boundaries however Simon and the
neighbors believe that the evil girl is
run away later the police informed the
couple that they found Clara's jacket in
a swamp however apart from that there
have been no other leads Paula is
worried that her little girl might be in
danger so she insists that the police
speed up the investigation once they are
alone at home Simon confronts his wife
he doesn't want to keep Clara anymore
even if she is found however Paula has
already connected with the child
emotionally so she wants otherwise they
get into a brief argument revealing more
about their past we learned that the
couple had been trying to become parents
for six years now and had sought the
help of fertility treatments but to no
avail presently they have decided to
stop the treatment and take some time
off the pressure but Paula has been
secretly continuing it turns out that
the injections she was hiding in the
washroom were the shots for the
treatment we also learned that Simon had
found out about this but he chose not to
say anything following their argument
Simon storms out of the house after a
while Paula receives a call in her
landline and hears Clara calling her
mama elated she quickly informs the
police about this number however when
the couple reaches the station the
police reveal that the phone call had
been made to Paula's home phone from her
very own mobile phone this convinces the
police and Simon that something must be
wrong with Paula's mental state so they
suggest she see a psychologist while
Paula is forced into taking a
psychological test she knows there's
more to the case decides to start an
investigation of her own the officer
then shows the couple two Case Files
which the authorities were going through
in order to find any trace of Clara
before heading out Paula cleverly takes
the files with her sitting in a nearby
restaurant she goes through the Case
Files one of them talks about missing
children in Germany and the other about
attacks against children from the same
country after checking for a while Paula
comes across a case where the body of a
teenage girl had been found with
punishment marks she takes a closer look
at the pictures of the crime scene and
notices this same paper designs that
Clara used to make for her convinced
that she might find a lead Paula goes to
meet with the doctor who had performed
the autopsy report of the murdered
teenage girl the latter reveals that the
girl had a damaged set of kidneys and
also a lazy eye meaning that one of her
eyes was weaker than the other alarmed
Paula once again goes through the file
of missing children's reports and
finally finds her big lead among the
cases there is a victim a young German
girl named Ingrid with a patch on one of
her eyes probably
a lazy eye or maybe her dad was a pirate
she had been kidnapped from a beach
around 10 years ago yep pirate and had
never been found since next Paula scours
the internet and finds a German article
and a video of Ingrid's parents talking
about her after she was missing for a
year in the video Ingrid's parents
mentioned how she used to craft those
trinkets give them to her loved ones and
call them Guardian Angels when Paula
returns home with all this information
she gives one of Clara's drawings
another look while sitting where the
girl used to sit she looks around and
finds that the drawing points to her
Eduardo who lives in the house across
from their home after thinking for a bit
it finally Dawns on Paula that Eduardo
has something to do with Clara's
disappearance hence she immediately
contacts the police before heading out
herself to inspect the scene then goes
into flashback to the night Clara was
found on the road Eduardo was traveling
in his car with Clara when he noticed a
police check going on near their house
scared he released the little girl and
instructed her to keep walking straight
on the road planning to catch up with
her later how however the girl met Paula
and her husband before that and was
rescued later Eduardo learned about the
news and became devastated one time
during dinner at Paula's house Eduardo
had excused himself from the Gathering
and managed to mix some shards of glass
inside a Jam Jar hoping to kill Clara
for he feared she might give away his
horrid crimes in another instance he
sneaked into the house stole Paula's
phone and called her landline from it he
then returned it back so as not to
arouse any suspicion the plan was to
make Paula look like a lunatic however
when nothing worked he once again broke
into the house and abducted Clara this
guy's plans are freaking weird back in
the present Paula decides to rescue the
little girl herself however by the time
she visits Eduardo's house the man has
already guessed that she knows about his
crimes he attacks her with a hammer
incapacitating her he then drags her
down to the basement where Clara is kept
restricted inside a chalk drawn boundary
and chains Paula to a pole following
this we get to know the exact story of
what happened Eduardo kidnapped Ingrid
years ago and impregnated her with Clara
before she was beaten to death this
confirms the German girl is actually
Claire's mother the little girl was kept
growing up in captivity and it was
Eduardo who had trained her to remain
confined inside lines of chalk by
punishing her regularly meanwhile based
on Paula's earlier call to the police
two officers arrive at Eduardo's door
but the Hopscotch killer manages to
drive them away with some lies then he
returns back to Paula and beats her up
asking how she knew about his secret the
latter reveals about the Case Files she
stole earlier and also mentions that
they are in her car hearing this Eduardo
immediately heads out adamant on
destroying the files so that his true
identity remains a mystery after he
leaves Paula tries to get help from
Clara she throws the girl a few pieces
of chalk that she had with her and
instructs Clara to draw her own path
towards the door of the basement the
little girl obliges and slowly she
starts moving out of the place Hopscotch
daddy returns after some time and
instantly notices the girl is missing
after he shouts around looking for Clara
slips out of the basement and locks its
door from outside she then reaches the
main door but hesitates to step out as
she cannot draw on the ground outside
just then she notices Simon and shouts
for help but he is too busy calling the
police as his partner has gone missing
hence with no options left Clara slowly
steps out of the chalk line and out of
the house by this time Eduardo's wife
Maita has also arrived at first she acts
politely and asks if Clara is lost but
after a while she changes her stance and
forcefully drags Clara back into the
house we learn that Maita herself is
always dominated by her controlling
husband and she now uses this
opportunity to take the upper hand over
Eduardo promising to keep the basement
and the two captives inside it a secret
from the world Maita demands he let her
do whatever she wants Eduardo agrees and
the two sit down for breakfast but their
agreement is short-lived as the police
force barges into the house and arrests
them it turns out that when Maita was
pulling Clara inside the house the girl
had left chalky Prince of her hands on
the main door and when the police
investigated the matter they quickly
realized that something was up in hop
Daddy's house the couple is arrested and
the two captives are rescued as well in
the last scene Clara who is now living
with her grandparents in Germany is seen
video chatting with Paula she has
finally started Living a normal life on
the other hand Paula is revealed to be
pregnant with her first child subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching